we have a defensive player of the year
draft and we are up against it we've got
nine picks to make i'm gonna give peter
the first pick then chris then me let's
see if we can get all three rounds in
defensive player of the year for 2020.
first on the clock is peter king go
i'm taking aaron donald and that's the
easiest pick in history chris go ahead
it is i was gonna say and i didn't get a
chance i was like can we just take aaron
donald off this uh draft this should be
the aaron donald memorial draft for for
what he does okay
um i'm gonna go with nick bosa next all
right 49ers off the edge you know that
defense is good i expect them to be good
i'll go with nick bosa
yeah i'm gonna go with t.j watt his
brother jj said yesterday i'll consider
him my peer when he wins a defensive
player of the year award maybe that's
the extra kick in the pants tj needs to
get over the top he was in the
conversation last year i'll take tj watt
give me khalil mack as my next pick and
i'll give you one very good reason
someone who knows khalil mack who used
to play with him uh in oakland told me
this off season
said he doesn't like being forgotten
about
you know and so i think he comes back
with a vengeance after playing hurt most
of last year
uh i mean if we have
a pool for nfl sac leader
uh the last two guys we've mentioned
mack and watt would have to be at the
top yeah definitely i mean mack is just
a marquee unbelievable football player
better than the stats say and you're
right akeem hicks wasn't there last year
he was banged up i'd watch out for
khalil mack too all right my next one
i'm gonna go with the the biggest trade
of the off-season i'm going with jamal
adams seattle if they somehow won the
nfc west or you know we're one of the
top defenses in football and he's got a
bunch of interceptions and sacks and
forced fumbles i think he is the the
perfect storm of that guy who could end
up being that troy palomalo defensive
mvp at the safety position
i'm amazed that this guy is still
available at the bottom of round two
because last year he was chris sims
odds-on favorite for defensive player of
the year and that's miles garrett of the
browns gone and forgotten because of
that suspension after whacking mason
rudolph over the head with his own
helmet he's back he's motivated he's
paid he's got help around him he's got a
new head coach who actually is suited to
be a head coach unlike last year's head
coach all due respect to freddie
kitchens but i think miles garrett is
the guy to get it done this year and i'm
amazed chris that you didn't take him
with either your first two picks no i i
know
you know what it was more about again
just like we always talk about it's a
they're a little unknown there in
cleveland i don't know what to expect
from the team so i think what we're
seeing so far is we're all picking
players for the most part other than
that one where the team is good and we
feel like it could work out i guess you
know but he's on my list my point is all
right so go ahead you're up peter
my uh my third one is going to be alden
smith
um wow
wow i got about 10 i got about 10 emails
yesterday when i listed him as the
number four person
on my list as the possible defensive
player of the year
and look
this is one of these absolutely
you know shooting a three from 50 feet
at half time
because no no everything about all this
smith now
this is this is you were with the doobie
brothers and you smoked a dude
hey how did you know mike
i don't know i got a little bird that
told me
the biggest thing the biggest thing
about alden smith and i'm doing
something in my nfl game pass thing with
him this week that do we remember
how great he was yeah when he was not on
alcohol or drugs or whatever it is that
you know ruined his career i mean do we
remember how great he was he was
unbelievably good
and to me
i just think
at age 30
he's ridiculously motivated by the way
running a 40 the same speed he ran it in
when he was 23 years old you know i
think he's tremendously motivated to be
great this year and believe me mike
mccarthy in dallas is going to give him
a chance to be great yeah i mean that
listen i'll call if you if that ends up
being right i'll i'll call you the
oracle for the rest of the year okay i'm
not even going to call you peter i'm
just going to call you oracle king okay
but that would be an unbelievable story
and you're right i mean when he was back
in his prime before issues like holy cow
he was a force to be reckoned with all
right i mean come on tampa's the team of
the the flavor of the month the team of
the month that the buccaneers do good
and brady has success
and shaq barrett does what he did last
year if he doesn't win defense mvp then
that'll be a crime i mean he's the least
talked about 19 and a half sack edge
rusher i've ever heard of in my life i
mean truly he was phenomenal in points
last year so you know that's another one
i just think if it lines up right the
team's successful and he puts that
statistical number out there like he did
last year it'd be hard not to vote for
him
yeah and and i agree with you i mean if
if this buccaneers offense really fires
on all cylinders and they build leads
what happens exactly the proverbial
pinning of the years back and off they
go and barrett on that franchise tag
every reason to play as effectively as
he did last year he was actually the pft
defensive player of the year not that
anybody cares about that all right last
pick and i'm a little nervous about this
because he's he's got a tweak
and i'm going to trust mike zimmer that
it's simply a tweak and nothing more but
you put yannick and gawkway across from
danielle hunter the guy whose name chris
has finally figured out how to pronounce
denial hunter is going to be a candidate
for defensive players he goes with his
team
he goes with his squad of the last pick
shocker he picked a white gig
who else anybody we missed peter who
else did you have on your list
i got three of my four so i'm pretty
happy wow good thing we didn't steal
some of those i wish i would have done
that so i could have seen you stumble
over these
how about this one how about this one
and i love a good story what about
janaevian clowning oh becoming defensive
player of the year showing up in
tennessee a week before the start of the
season and off we goes how about that
never had never had a double digit sack
year we didn't even talk about the guy
who won defensive player last year just
to let everybody know i mean stefan
gilmore would be somebody that we
probably should have drafted there's a
few other guys well now he's got
motivation for this year that's
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports